hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to claytown horror um
[Music]
my name is william brin
you're an exorcist going to an old
deserted house in order to rid it of its
haunts you've never taken on a task as
horrid as this however too many people
have been taken by the things that lurk
within those walls and tonight you will
put an end to it
or i'll die trying which seems like the
more likely option
huh
doesn't seem like a very clay town if
you ask me
i'm also a child
all right
well maybe this is more of a clay town
than i thought but also i suspect that
this house is unique
in its cardboard aesthetics
i'm sorry what am i hearing
did you say take it did i get a whisper
saying take it lixian did you say take
it i should take it are you saying that
i should take
take
it
thanks
what
i missed what that was i'll just toss
the lady onto the chandelier that way it
can't get out
i'll toss the key
not though
what
okay
hmm
interesting
gotta say
fascinating aesthetics
i'll do what you say
thanks flexion
your influence is incredible
your advice
unflappable
okay so i don't have the tool with which
to cut it
oh
is that a hand or is that a
no it's not a hand it's just a
doll's body
why
huh
okay
so i need to find something to cut that
and there's several keys that i
need that my footsteps good
is that a chaise lounge
is that them teeth
eat it
eat it
you need it i need it i need it
[Applause]
i needed that
i needed that incredibly
okay not that key
i don't like that i have to push open
the doors with my face
just means that i have to enter the room
whatever i want to rementer
in to
where's everything so big
i'm not usually this short i don't think
i'm supposed to get up here but
i'm up here
well mission accomplished
read it
okay
crumpled letter
please
i need you to come
hug me
my very soul has been scared and every
day i feel i'm
and every day i feel i'm closer and
closer to
[Music]
waiting
bakerly
no player
the
book
just drive me raving
i think there's probably a way to resume
okay i can barely look in the mirror no
matter how much i scrub my skin still
feels stained please i need you here
with me you're the only one who seems to
understand the only one who doesn't
judge me one way or another please come
stay at the house for a few weeks and
help me feel like me again i'm so afraid
to sleep alone another night and what i
might do please i need you
monika
okay
well
always love getting those notes monica
i'm sure that was for me
and here i am
oh outside
okay not there gotta say
curious as to what this place was for
can i look through oh hey buddy
hi
all right bye hey
okay um toy room key maybe this one
maybe the one upstairs
oh
oh god i don't like the eyes
hi
hey
[Music]
great stuff
super happy to be here
hey
ah
oh
i don't like how bloody that knife is
sorry buddy were you looking at me
oh
okay well i can cut this thing get
another key then mosey on my way out of
here
am i lou
oh it's dark now i thought that
oh
oh oh no
oh no
i got a hand light
don't ask me how that's powered because
i don't know
where have i seen that before
i've definitely seen that
is it over here yeah with you buddy
hi
oh okay
i like that i'm holding this like a
sword
oh
is it is it important
this is probably the most disconcerting
thing i've seen in a video game in a
while like seeing you talking to me like
that is just so creepy
all right basement key don't know why
i'd want that
i swear this thing was breathing
wow i don't like that
okay basement key has been obtained
i forget what it looked like it was like
a box
here
hello
oh
i don't remember that note being there
basement warning
that don't sound good i think i'm safe
for now i don't know what that thing is
but i lured it into that gallery and
locked the
oh door was just in the gallery why
would you need to lock the door i just
need to find a way out of here
wait where did that key go
you're telling me that i shouldn't have
gone in the gallery is that what you're
telling me
okay
oh
okay
well that's bad
hi
oh my god
don't know how me putting the chandelier
down turned off all the lights
doesn't seem like equivalent exchange
what
well that wasn't there before
you still there oh
no
oh no
oh no that's bad knock knock who's there
oh
oh
i'm in here now apparently
am i supposed to remember this number
because i'm not good at that five two
one nine seven four eight nine one three
eight six four two seven oh seven six
two five
all right guys you know the drill write
that down
[Music]
oh
does it correspond to the pan
it corresponds to the paintings in here
hi
okay whatever you're here now so
zero there's a zero over there there's
ones over there i don't know if i need
to like select them in order there's a
zero there and there
zero
i don't know what is whispering to me
oh
oh it's a safe
ah
[Applause]
i see okay oh magnificent image how the
snakes ruin you oh magnificent mind how
the ravens loathe you oh magnificent
justice how the judge heeds you oh
magnificent love
oh magnificent light
oh magnificent blight
how am i awake
by your side
okay so this is clear image snakes
so i need to look for an image with the
snakes
sick
okay and then i look at the
corresponding thing for that let me
actually just look at the poem because
the snakes ravens judge heart reaper
awakeness so snake up there
raven
over there
judge judge judge judge
that's fine
judge
judge judge okay so snake was up there
raven over there judge there okay so
that's the first few numbers i think let
me just get a little peekaboo here all
right so one two
two one two two that's the first few
numbers i think so one two two heart
reaper wake i saw a heart over here
reaper probably the grim reaper
maybe that um
not seeing anything that could be awake
oh bed bed bed let's try that okay so
bed all the way in the corner to the
opposite of that wall and then that one
there okay
oh my god okay so bed five
seven no
five
five nine seven it'll either be five
seven seven or five nine seven i don't
wanna look in here again i'd rather not
which one was it
the one oh i was wrong on both fronts
oh i gotta look in here again okay buddy
zero
five zero seven
hey
one two two five zero seven great
one two two five zero seven please
i nailed it
should give peekaboo one more time
oh no
oh no
no why is it worse
[Music]
it's fine
[Applause]
a sturdy basement key oh good
oh good okay well now that that is over
with i'm good
all safe now i don't have anything to
worry about
don't want to answer that door
so i'm the one who knocks
i am the one who knocks okay
all right
great oh good
oh god
no i don't want to open the door
oh
i'm alive for some reason
don't know why
but i'm alive or am i
oh
what a fun smile
all right well i got this basement
key and i'm gonna just go ahead and use
it no time like the present
nothing's good
stand in my way
good
worked like a charm
oh i forgot that it was the basement
oh
oh
why is it wet
why does this have to be moist i prefer
dry
must you drip
must the
drip
all right good
all according to plan
there's something down here i'm supposed
to oh
stop it stop it
stop it
i won't say this again kids do not
bother me when i'm in my studio
if you have something to say talk to me
when i'm not working
okay whatever
well that's clearly not the door that i
need to go to because someone is busy
working in their studio
and they need to not be bothered
far be it for me to bother someone when
they wish not to be bothered
just like me right now i would rather
not be bothered
it's important is it important is it
what is it
oh the den oh it's there was a dart
board i remember that
this is down along an ominous hallway
and i'm sure there's gonna be nothing
weird when i turn around and go back
upstairs
so far so good
i think i'm going to get out of here
a-okay
yeah
nothing to worry about here
oh
oh that was so
goddamn good
what the hell
you can't have a demo that good
i was so into that really really good
stuff oh man that was fantastic that was
great that's good stuff i can't wait for
the full version of this support this
game so we can get more of this link in
the description below thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]